foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so if you're looking if you have a a
heart and a love for kiddos and would
like to be willing to serve once every
three weeks not every Sunday
then we'd like for you to fill out a
little card on the tiny table in the
hallway give us your name your number
put in the comments kids ministry
you can choose your age group that you'd
like to work with
Pre-K
listen I speak loud enough I don't need
this mic
so I'm trying to be really
I'm trying to be really nice to the mic
okay
all right so you can choose your age
group
Pre-K kindergarten or Nursery or you can
do the elementary age kiddos and you can
also be a helper and that way you won't
have to be the primary teacher
okay so now let us prepare for worship
dear Creator we give you thanks for this
Gathering of your children
you have made us in love
we pray that you will reveal this great
love to us today
As We Gather to worship
we are blessed to be led by your holy
spirit amen
I wanted to take a quick second to
introduce we're going to try a new song
Tonight It's called I'm so blessed by a
group named
Caitlin gets the credit for this song
she introduced me to Kane
and um
I just have to say really quick I when
she first sent it to me like I loved the
groove I I'm a fan of some gospel feels
and it had that gospel feel to it and I
was like excited and then I listened to
the words and I like totally shut it out
and I was like no I am turning this down
because it has this phrase over and over
I'm so blessed I'm so blessed and I've
gotten really burnt out on the like
hashtag blessed you know like grateful
thankful blessed everywhere and I just
started to get real cynical towards that
whole idea and and then I kind of took a
moment to try to get introspective and
figure out like what's going on there
and why am I so
um turned off by this and I realized
I've kind of attached this message to
the word blessing or the word blessed
that's all tied into circumstances it's
all tied into what's going on if you get
the promotion if your prayer against
gets answered and
um you know whatever good things come
along in your life determine whether you
are blessed or not and then it kind of
becomes this In Crowd and this outcrowd
because what happens when it doesn't go
that way you know like when my prayer
wasn't answered when I was at my lowest
and my most broken and hurting really
badly I was like this is not fair for
those people like this messaging is not
you know an inclusive message from God
that's you know like why would there be
some blessed people and some unblessed
people
but I realized like my messaging is
wrong because blessing from God is not
about our circumstances as much as it is
our identity in Christ about who he
created us to be as a child of God and
every Sunday We Gather here and we um
say a benediction at the end of our
service right like Karen or someone will
close us out and they'll say you are a
child of God you are a child of God and
I can get behind that messaging I can
get behind the message that we were
created in love
that God is on the side of the
Brokenhearted like the Beatitudes that's
blessing
blessed are the Brokenhearted blessed
are the poor in spirit blessed are the
crushed you know for they will see God
they will see the kingdom of heaven and
so
I don't want to belabor this point
anymore I'm sure Jesse's hands are going
to get tired but I just wanted to kind
of present that view of blessing to you
guys in case it's helpful in case you've
been a little jaded like me
um and need to kind of rework our
framework around blessing
um our kids ministry has been talking
about it and Maggie what was the
definition you guys what did you say was
uh to be in a position to see the
kingdom of God all right I just loved
those words like let's approach blessing
as asking like and wanting to be in that
place where we can see his kingdom where
we can feel his love where we can see
his hand in our life all right because
there's no in and out crowd of that like
we all have that opportunity so
um let's let's remember the bigger story
and not just what's presently happening
circumstantially but what God is doing
in the earth redeeming restoring drawing
us to himself all right
[Music]
Hallelujah
I'm a child of God and on my worst day
I'm a Child of God oh every day is a
good day
though it doesn't matter
[Music]
gone
and I count the ways you're good to me
you've got me counting all day long
it doesn't matter again
does it matter
by you Lord I'm so blessed on my best
day I'm a Child of God on my worst day
I'm a Child of God oh every day is a
good day
Hallelujah
I'm blessed
all right thank you guys kids y'all are
dismissed to go to your classrooms oh no
be careful
[Music]
no one's in trouble but I'm glad you
didn't get hurt
all right preschool kiddos can come to
this classroom over to our left if there
are any in our schoolers over here with
Devin and Anna thank you Devin Anna
Kelly and any other kids ministry
workers tonight that are back there in
the nursery and Eve Angie so so grateful
for you guys really appreciate how y'all
speak into our kids lives
all right Caitlyn is going to lead us in
our prayers of the people so if you guys
would read aloud with her and then share
your requests or whatever you're
carrying on your heart and those of you
who are online feel free to leave it in
the comments and then we'll continue
with our mission
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and will to conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and Light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Applause]
[Music]
ities
that I've never been more glad that I
put my faith in Jesus
he's never let me down he's faithful
through
generations
so I would he
leave you alone
I know you won't know
I still got joy
in your eyes
I've got peace that makes no sense so I
won't be going
straight cause I build my life on Jesus
and he's never let me down he's faithful
in every season
so why would he feel now he will
face
[Music]
we are
on he will say
he will face
Christ is my firm foundations
[Music]
but I've never been more glad that I put
my faith in Jesus
cause he's never let me down faithful to
Generations
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
the rain came
in blue my house was built on you
dimes
with you I'm gonna make it through
rain came wind
blew but my house was built on you
and I'm safe with
you I'm gonna make it through sing that
again
[Music]
came with blue my house was built on you
and I'm gonna make it through
cause I'm standing strong on you
I'm gonna make it through
cause my house is built on you
cause I'm standing strong on you
I'm gonna make it through cause my house
was built on you
[Music]
Because He Lives
I Can Face Tomorrow
oh fear is gone
because I know
he holds the future
in life is worth living just because he
will
God sent his son
they called in Jesus
he came to love
[Music]
healing
forgive
he bleed and died
too by my part in
in empty grave his death
My Savior Lives
[Music]
Because He
Lives
I Can Face Tomorrow
Because He Lives
all fear is gone
because I know
he holds the future
and life is worth living just because
[Music]
how sweet too
the newborn baby
enjoy he gives
but greater still
the karma assurance
this child can face
uncertain days because Christ
lives
Because He Lives
that can face tomorrow
cause you live
all fear is
gone
because I know
he holds the future
in life is worth living just because he
lives
in one day
no cross the river
I'll fight lives
[Music]
gives way to Victory
I'll see the lights of glory and I'll
know
Because He Lives
oh fear is gone
cause I know
it's the future
in life is worth living just because he
lives
[Music]
foreign
with the knowledge of Christ
be our anchor
would your love be the thing that
grounds us
regardless of circumstance or loss or
pain
God would there be a strength that goes
beyond that
that holds us fast
knowing that the story is not over
and that after death comes Resurrection
[Music]
God would we celebrate that life would
we celebrate what you have given us in
Jesus
[Music]
the hope of all things being restored
the hope of all things being made new
would it happen in US
[Music]
we love you Jesus and we're grateful
we're grateful for that kind of love
keep holding on to us
it's in your name we pray all these
things amen
as you guys get seated could you turn to
the people around you and just welcome
them make them feel at home and then
Brett will get us started on our message
all right well Grace and peace it is uh
it's so so good to be with you all and
um I want to that includes as always
those joining us online
love y'all lots and um and anyone here
who is new thank you so much for being
Among Us it means a lot
um I know it can take a lot of courage
to walk through those doors and enter
into a new space new community
um I even see some head snotting of
people who have been here a while but
they remember the feeling you know and
um that's you know it can just be a lot
so all they just say I'm just really
glad that you're that you're here and I
also wanted before I keep moving I
wanted to mention just to give a huge
thank you to Jesse Watts for preaching
for me last week it was really good
okay
you want to say anything or I'm missing
he's like oh my gosh why are you doing
this to me Brett
um but he really it was just a great
great message and uh yeah I'm grateful
um and we something we're working on is
to just keep um having other folks up
here uh so you'll see that um more so
than in in years past uh and I'm I think
that's a great thing so uh we are in
let's see it's uh third Sunday in our
series and in the season
um known as Easter tide so our our uh
our series is Easter tide this is not
the end and uh I know if many of us grew
up you know in Easter was like very much
a one day thing
um and it's you can see though where
like so just the last few years as a
church we started to engage the practice
or the season of lint which kind of
leads up to like Good Friday and
um that's of course 40 days you know of
that and you can see where when you
start to practice lint and for those
familiar it's you know this kind of time
of spiritual preparation so often people
fast something and maybe you're
intentional about some spiritual
disciplines and things so you can see
where when you do that it's a little bit
strange that in celebrate Easter for a
day because it was like a lot of work
you know I mean like Ash Wednesday and
it's you know the ashes on our head it's
sort of a downer and and all the
reflections on the cross and it can be a
kind of intense season I think it could
be good
um I mean it admittedly for some kind of
triggering and a little bit difficult
depending on your kind of you know
spiritual like background and such but
overall I think it can be very powerful
and good you can see where the church
um kind of balanced that with 40 days of
preparation and then 40 days of
Celebration and so that's what Easter
tide is about is a season of feasting a
season of celebration of remembering uh
week after week that Christ has risen
not just the one uh Easter message and
then it's sort of like all right back to
the Grind
um instead it's uh really a season of
Joy so um so that's kind of uh what this
this whole series in in time is about
um as we kind of realize that East
sister is not like a Finish Line
but it's really a starting line for us
in our own uh as we kind of walk with
Christ so with that in mind the title of
my message this third Sunday of Easter
tide is breathe
breathe I hope that's peaceful everyone
take a deep breath
sometimes we need that after a long week
our text where I'm getting this is uh
from John chapter 20 verses 19 through
22.
and it begins like this
on the evening of the first day of the
week when the disciples were together
with the doors locked
for fear of the Jewish leaders
Jesus came and stood among them and said
peace be with you
after he said this he showed them his
hands and his side right presumably
because they're just completely
astonished and like oh my gosh I cannot
believe this so he's like it's really me
you know showing them the scars
it continues the disciples were
Overjoyed when they saw the Lord again
Jesus said peace be with you as the
father has sent me I am sending you
we'll get more into that next week
verse 22 and with that he breathed on
them
and said receive the Holy Spirit
so there are several
interesting moments in this passage but
the the one I want to focus on is of
course as you know from the title that
moment of the breathing
and I'm curious about how that you know
how that struck you I mean it is
admittedly it's a strange thing right
I'm just imagining if like one Sunday I
was like come on everyone out of your
seats you don't have to do this but
everyone come on ever huddle around me
gather around I'm like are you ready
you're just all looking at me like okay
I'm like all right here we go
you know you just be like
okay interesting this is the weirdest
church service I've ever been to uh and
I can't say that it's like well if only
you understood first century Jewish
culture well then you would see that
this is totally normal they did this all
the time uh but no no this is uh a
unique moment and it sort of begs the
question you know like what on Earth is
uh is going on here like what did this
mean for Jesus what did it mean uh for
them
so let's go back a little bit to
understand this in in more depth so
throughout the scriptures uh the breath
has very deep associations with the
spirit of God uh in fact the the Hebrew
word for
um
spirit is
which means a number of different things
it means breath it means wind and it
means spirit so like obviously in
English we have these three different
words to kind of talk and probably we
would think of you know breath and wind
as sort of I don't know just physical
things secular you know not spiritual or
whatever
um and then Spirit we'd say oh that's
you know religious uh but not in the
break mind not not in that culture it
was breath wind spirit uh it was really
all it was all the same and if we go
back to uh the very earliest chapters of
the Bible Genesis chapter 2 there's a
very key moment of Ruah and we'll begin
in verse four says this is the account
of the heavens and the earth when they
were created when the Lord God made the
Earth in the heavens
now no shrub had yet appeared on the
earth no plant had yet sprung up for the
Lord God had not sent rain on the earth
there was no one to work the ground but
streams came up from the earth and
watered the whole surface of the ground
then the Lord God formed a man from the
dust of the ground we'll pause there so
you can kind of see that it's like this
moment of creation and you have this uh
this what the the Hebrew there is adamah
um like the human one has been made but
it's it's just like the outer form you
might say like the shell of a human
being in other words it it doesn't yet
have uh life
and so what happens
well verse 7 then the Lord God formed
this adamawa this man from the dust of
the ground and did what
and breathed into his nostrils the
breath of life and that man became a
living being
so notice here what a what a mystery
life is
uh that that it's this moment where I
mean the fact that we have like
Consciousness awareness uh life like
here we are oh my gosh like what a
miracle it is if uh of course been like
to uh to a funeral and had like an open
casket and there's that that sense of
like okay there they are and yet they're
gone
you know it's like well that's their
body but not some essential part of that
the person I knew that you know what
what is that
that mystery
well Genesis 2 says it's Rua
because what happens God comes and
breathes life into this first human
being and in suddenly it's filled with
spirit and it's no longer like an it now
it's it's um in this case uh he
uh so you know I think sometimes uh Even
in our own kind of world we can feel you
know like uh kind of distant from God
like just our religious imaginations
like we're here and God is out there
somewhere
and you know it's even it's kind of a
felt sense of that of just like I don't
feel close to God I I don't know this is
like not very real for me at times
uh and yet if if you think about it
are you breathing
then already
it has begun
in you
already
God's spirit Rua in out in out in every
moment of your existence like a Grace
has already kissed you
God's present nearness is already upon
you
sustaining you in every moment
but as we'll see that's really just the
beginning
uh so come back to or I should say
forward fast forward now 2000 years or
so a few thousand years
um from Genesis 2 we're back to John 20.
the disciples are all gathered in this
room and of course at this point like
they've journeyed with Jesus uh for
three years so they've like heard you
know all his Greatest Hits every sermon
um which you know he's probably sort of
like um any religious like teacher
traveling religious teacher or uh uh
Community organizer where they have kind
of stump speeches you know it's like the
thing that's probably what we have
captured in the gospels are not like
some unique thing he said like one time
that was it it's sort of like you know
these are the things that he said over
and over and over and so they've heard
it all seen it all I mean been there for
every miracle and yet at this point
probably about all they could do would
be to kind of imitate Jesus in some way
like they know his stump speeches we'll
just keep giving those speeches
you know we'll just do what Jesus did
uh and yet what's so interesting
um
is
that that at this point
um well I think in many ways like this
is often how we think of the Christian
Life like we too need to like imitate
Jesus but it's interesting that
um that's not what Jesus calls them to
like a sort of external clunky kind of
imitation of him
uh he does something different one
metaphor I was thinking of uh or an
analogy was uh my wife Maggie teaches uh
mainly piano lessons but she does some
voice lessons
and mainly with um uh young children and
so I'm like I work from home so I'm like
I'm there for it you know I hear every
all the piano playing and the singing
and everything and
um you know most of the kids like they
have good voices like it's you know it's
good um you know some of them they're in
voice lessons for a reason and that's
okay you know gotta learn
um but mostly it gets it's pleasant but
what's one interesting thing I've
noticed
and it becomes very obvious uh at
recitals especially maybe because like
everyone's there uh just staring you
know and they feel pressure but I've
noticed um they tend to imitate
uh often the the female singers will
imitate Adele that seems to be their
vocalist of choice I don't know why but
maybe because I mean it's a beautiful
voice I guess so that's that
um and but they will that's like and
again like they have a nice voice
but they're not yet comfortable
in their own voice you notice they like
need kind of a buffer or something like
okay I'm not really confident that I
have what it takes and that my voice is
nice and so what am I gonna do I'm gonna
I'm gonna imitate someone else because I
know they're awesome and they're
acceptable and everyone like they
certainly had people's approval and so
I'm just gonna go ahead and do my Adele
oppression and that feels you know a
little bit uh a little bit safer
um
and I think this is why Jesus doesn't
look at the disciples and say friends
peace be with you
imitate me do everything exactly the way
I did I gave you the formula
so this is how you do it you know say
preach the exact sermons I preach in the
same way you know uh he doesn't call
them to that
and said what does he do
verse 22 and with that he breathed on
them and he said receive the Holy Spirit
in other words
the the very spirit of God that fully
inhabited him
he then bestows upon them
and the truth for us today is that
Christ does the exact same thing for
every single one of us
Christ breathes on us and we receive God
not as some external thing but like
within us
so what does this mean like for our own
lives I'm I'm being a little bit uh I
don't know kind of cheeky here with this
statement but I hope you'll get what I'm
getting at uh so here's the take home
phrase don't imitate Christ
become Christ
uh and I realize that can I don't know
how that strikes you you know kind of
overly uh extreme in some way
um but I do think there's a lot of Truth
in this like in other words what's
what's the Christian call
well it's really I think at a deep level
to allow God's spirit to infuse every
cell of our body
to live in complete and total surrender
but it's in it's like an inner
transformation that then manifests
outwardly but we don't have to go around
I don't know pretending you know like
trying to be something we really deepen
our bones feel like I am so not that
but I'm just gonna go ahead and pretend
because I'm a Christian
and so that's what it takes uh no I
think think we're missing it in other
words the more infused by the Holy
Spirit I am the more perfectly myself
and Christ
I become
all at the same time
uh and and why is that because it kind
of sounds like how can I be like more
like Christ and yet more fully myself
well it's because the God who is Father
son's spirit is your creator the very
source of your being and life and so it
makes sense that like the more of God in
you so to speak uh like the more fully
human you become the more Fully Alive
wind breath Spirit more fully animated
you become the more fulfilled you you
feel and at the same time the more like
Christ uh you are becoming
uh and I think some of why this is is we
tend to think of like well there's you
know God I got spirit and that's so
again it's so disconnected from me you
know what what am I I'm nothing uh and
and yet it seems that
um
that while there is I'm not saying like
literally like we all become egomaniacs
like I'm God you know that'd be weird
um but but in the sense of it's not that
Divinity in humanity are somehow or the
Creator and creation are just utterly
oil and water and never the two shall
mix in any way but there's a deep um
connection I mean at least if Jesus if
that moment of breathing
is to be trusted where we're like taking
God into us
uh coming back to the Adele analogy I'm
kind of imagining you're like what what
should those students do like rather
than a kind of clunky external imitation
you know
like
I don't know whatever you know
um that's a terrible Adele on version
um
you know instead of this kind of like
yeah that clunky thing um
I wonder thinking even of what artists
do you know I've talked about this
before how like a great artist is really
um tuning into that more that's there
and tune into God
and like becoming a channel for that
that beauty and truth and goodness
and I think that's what Adele does so
well is like it's that Raw it's turning
to that um that kind of raw vulnerable
place where you're just like bleeding on
that stage you know
and like in essence that's what we have
to learn right but but what do we so
often do we kind of settle for the
external outward imitation you know I
don't know someone like wants to start
wearing this stuff Adele wears you know
I mean like we're trying to get the
tonal quality just like Adele gets
instead of
um
becoming that
that channel for God's spirit like
thinking of uh kind of bringing it back
to church world we often have our like
mentors and I don't know people in the
faith may like we look up to and what's
the Temptation always at the beginning
we like imitate the externals uh I
noticed this there's I won't say his
name but there's like a celebrity Pastor
in the area and a good teacher like
really good but I've noticed that
anytime someone uh would like fulfill
like fill in and preach for him like
they just like were doing an imitation
of him you know I mean the qualities and
even the dress
and the whole thing you know what I mean
and this is I'm not like trying to shame
them or something like this is kind of
natural this is you know what we do
um but you can see where it's it's uh
kind of shallow like I'm thinking of
even my kiddos who um love like they
love soccer my voice and so they want to
you know become Cristiano Ronaldo but
what do they think do they think oh yeah
to become him I'm gonna start doing two
hours of drills a day you know no they
want to get his cleats
you know and this is honestly this is
like all branding and marketing is like
hey you want to be that ideal don't you
put on this t-shirt you know like you
can see where it's clunky uh I'm imagine
even the context of the disciples like
we need to dress those remember those
robes Jesus always wore let's be sure to
get his row like those nice those were
great but people seem to really respond
to his row you know or he had that that
way of speaking and let's imitate that
or he was a carpenter we should all be
Carpenters that's really the trade
that's the spiritual you know it's like
okay okay
no that's not what Jesus died he doesn't
invite them into like imitate everything
about me no he's he breathes on them
he breathes on them and he says now the
very spirit that inhabited me I'm giving
it to you and it's going to be in you
and it's going to come out your fingers
and your toes and it's going to flood
you and it's going to transform you from
the inside out and you're going to be
more of gods than you've ever been and
more of yourself all at the same time
and like that's the Christian Life in
call again don't imitate Jesus by that I
mean you know in this kind of external
outward clunky way
um become
Christ allow God's spirit into you let
it transform and fulfill so what are
like the implications of this some of
this I've already hinted at but I just
want to draw it out
um number one the imitation of you know
models and mentors and spiritual leaders
that all has its place
but the way to really honor them is not
to imitate them you might say it's to
take in the good that they've modeled
and still be you you know I'm thinking
of like what's the good they've modeled
probably a good word here would be like
um virtue or character you know it's
like in other words this is the
Galatians um it talks about the fruit of
the spirit you know love a joy a peace a
patience a kindness a goodness the Jonas
a faithfulness of self-control and
there's others you know it wasn't trying
to be exhaustive we could talk about
integrity and courage
and like when we're thinking of you know
um becoming Christ and what happens when
God's spirit gets in us like this is
what begins to transform in US but
what's so beautiful is that when those
character traits when that gets in you
you're still you
without needing to like be someone else
I'm thinking uh for example like the way
that I will
um love people like be present and show
up for others is um just completely
different than many of you
and that's good
that's okay right and that would be bad
to be like oh you see how I don't know
Pastor Brad or sometimes people have
that thing with the pastors I don't know
like that's how he does it you know so I
want to do that or be that or it's like
oh no no no just stop like
um no you just you be you
and and take but you've got to kind of
discern okay what does it look like for
me to love
how does peace manifest in me is this
something that drives me a little bit
crazy in um because I if you've been
around a while you know I'm kind of into
like monastic folks and monks and nuns
in the Christian
um and otherwise but that kind of
tradition and there's kind of a certain
you know the contemplative life and such
and there's kind of this weird vibe
where it's almost expected that you're
kind of I don't know like you know if
you're a monk or a nun and you're
saintly and so you're like you know
you're quiet
you're a quiet Soul and Spirit
you'd never Raise Your Voice or get too
excitable
and it's like
it gets weird like I've even seen this
in kind of like um for lack of a better
term kind of new age circles where like
everyone has this sort of you know
I'm just at peace all the time
you know it's all good and you can kind
of feel at times like oh no but is that
real or is it just that you're imitating
you know what I mean like oh I've got to
be at peace as you can kind of see the
rage built up behind you know I mean but
it's like I've got to be and we do that
we have our own version of trying to
pick on other religious Traditions but
you know like we have our own versions
of that gotta be humble you know and I
don't know or peaceful or gotta be happy
gotta be a happy Christian because
that's what Christians are and so we
gotta you can see where we just we do
this thing and it just it's like uh use
the biblical metal metaphor it's it's
like Saul's armor on David if you know
the story War of the armor was just like
this doesn't fit
you know that's that's kind of what I'm
getting at like it has its place that
but eventually we've gotta learn a
different way of becoming
um second implication and I'll close
with this to receive the Holy Spirit
um Just Surrender more and more to God
to become like Jesus will involve
transformation but it's not a violent
diminishment of me it's an expansion of
my true self
in other words one way to interpret this
whole message would be like I don't know
in an overly simplistic way would be
like you know you do you
and I think there's truth in that you
know I've even used that phrase and it's
not a bad phrase like there's a lyric
because if by that we mean everything
I've been talking about you know step
into the fullness of who of who you are
in Christ and you know and so on that's
like a healthy thing but when it becomes
like hey I'm just like I've seen people
like the utter jerks and it's kind of
like that's just who I am
you ever had this have you ever maybe
you've ever been that person I have yeah
um you know I mean that's and that's not
good so just to be clear that's not what
I'm talking about it's like well I'm
just myself and you don't like it that's
your problem you know it's like what do
you mean by is it that you're just being
a jerk like in other words
um there are things in us that are
twisted that are wrong that are off
um but but I think the kind of truth
would be but that's not who God's called
us to be and that's not who we really
are
from an identity perspective
and so the process that God invites us
into is actually
um a stepping or a withering away of
those things in a stepping into the
fullness of who I am in God I think of
my daughter when she was very young
about five years old she was adamantly
opposed to baptism
and because she had heard that when
you're baptized
you are changed
transformed like a new person
and if you know my daughter she is
Enneagram eight
and like fiercely committed to being
herself and she wants you to be yourself
and if you're not she will fight with
people to make sure you can be you if
she even fight with you it feels like
you're not being you like she will like
you beat you you know I committed to
this and so she hated the idea of
baptism like oh my gosh no people don't
need to change that's what she told me
people don't need to change they're fine
as they are
and so she said in her little
five-year-old way and she said just you
know I'm never getting baptized was her
little cute phrase
um
and of course like she kind of you know
grew up a little bit and she ultimately
was baptized but um but you can see the
truth and I think it is the true thing
that she's hitting on
right of like are you saying I have to
become someone very different than who I
am right and that's the Nuance right and
I think that's the beauty of this
breathing moment because you can see
it's not like oh God's Gonna Fill Me and
now it's like a a violence upon me you
know you change your personality you
change who you are you know it's not no
no but it's a it's a withering away of
what is false or twisted or not who I
really am and then it's an enlivening
of God's spirit within me uh healing
healing work
so friends this Easter tide breathe
breathe in and receive God's holy spirit
breathe out and be transformed in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit amen
so as we come to the table
of the Lord today
as we take in the body of Christ in the
bread the blood of Christ and the wine
may it be a moment
where we just like those first disciples
receive the spirit
may we receive the bread in the wine
may we receive Christ through the spirit
people often wonder how is it that
Christ is like present in Bread and Wine
and the answer is through the spirit
through this ruach
this mystery of God all around and
within us and so as you take it in May
that which is not really you just a
little bit of it may it be diminished
in May that which is you and exactly who
God has called you to be and become
may it flourish
so
the way we're going to do this will just
kind of start here at the front and work
our way back you should also know that
the red is wine real wine and the white
is grape juice that can be quite a
startling surprise for some sometimes so
and I think a few weeks ago we forgot to
mention it in some little kid I was like
he's turning to his friend like
I was like uh-oh hope his parents aren't
mad so the red is wine
um and uh also we practice what's called
an Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you want to participate in
this moment if something in you wants to
connect with Christ
uh maybe you don't have like all the
perfect theology worked out or whatever
um but if something in you like I want
to come forward I want to connect with
Christ then you are welcome to do that
having said that there's no Stigma or
pressure if you if you don't want to um
that's perfectly fine too so uh this is
the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed come
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
you guys are welcome to remain seated if
you would like if you're still
reflecting or you're also welcome to
stand with us and sing this last song
just kind of inviting more of God to
fill us
[Music]
kind of living into that breath of
Christ and inviting him into us
[Music]
I just want more
of you God more of you God I just want
more I just want more
of
you guys
[Music]
lay down all I am making room for you
Lord I'm ready
to open up my heart to receive not
Empire
fullness of who you are Lord I'm ready
I just want more
of you guys
[Music]
lay down all I am making room for you
Lord I'm ready
to open up my heart
to receive not impart the fullness of
who you are Lord I'm ready I just want
more
I just want more
of you guys
I want more of you
just one touch from your robe use the
weakness from my bones
[Music]
my heart come and heal
just one touch from your rope steals the
weakness
I just want more I just want more
of you God
[Music]
please
thank you
[Music]
hey thank you so much for joining us
this evening
if you're someone that's new to our
community
we'd really love for you to fill out a
card and information card on the tiny
table in the hallway
that will allow us to follow up with you
and answer any questions that you may
have
and also to just say thank you for
visiting with us
so if you're in need of a hug or a
prayer or any other General support my
name is johneen and I will be in the
back and would be loved to be there for
you in any way that I can
here at the table we're committed to
creating an inclusive community that
touches lives and supports other
like-minded non-profits
we believe that generous giving
is the key component to building the
kind of community that we envision
so we are grateful for those of you who
have partnered with us already
and for any of you who are considering
joining us you're able to give online at
thetabletexas.org
or you can put your donation in the
little box on the tiny little table in
the hallway I just love that tiny little
table in the hallway
also don't forget that the kids ministry
needs you
so fill out a card
and also don't forget to look online to
see if there is a meetup group that
you'd be interested in or if you'd like
to form one
so now let me send you out with this
benediction
may God bless you and keep you
because you are a child of God
may God's breath fall upon you
for you are a child of God
you are a child of God on your best day
and it is true that you are a child of
God on your worst day
so as you go into the week ahead with
all of its highs and lows and everything
in between
go with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are accepted Just As You Are
[Music]
so go filled with God's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of love compassion and Grace to
everyone you come into contact with this
week
have a great evening and we look forward
to seeing you next Sunday right here
[Music]
I want more of you
just one touch from your rope
[Music]